will live in the age of great astronomic
achievements over 5 000 Distant Worlds
are known to us thanks to today's
orbital telescopes most of those places
are truly wonderful
unique and mysterious
and sometimes extremely dangerous
there are planets out there illuminated
by two or three stars at the same time
whereas others are eternally shrouded in
the darkness of space
some of these worlds Inspire Terror by
their extreme conditions While others
make one Marvel at their bizarre
features we have already been on a
journey to the most horrifying planets
before
it's time to move on to other objects
[Music]
today's internet Technologies allow us
to travel to remote planets in the
comfort of our home meanwhile artificial
limitations are gradually being imposed
across the world wide web which prevents
us from fully appreciating its
capabilities
surfsharkvpn may help you to deal with
that you can get instant access to your
favorite sites internet shop catalogs or
online video platforms by connecting to
the service for example you are free to
watch your favorite movies and series on
Netflix or use Messengers to call your
friends in countries where they are
blocked besides the server will encrypt
your data to protect it from scammers
and will hide your location from web
observers use the QR code and screen or
the link in the description for an 83
discount and three months of free
subscription as a bonus you if you
manage to find a better offer within 30
days you'll get your money back from
surfshark explore new opportunities of
Limitless and safe internet access with
surfsharkvpn and in the meantime let's
continue our flight through the expanses
of space
as a rule it's potentially habitable
planets with favorable conditions and a
moderate climate that especially catch
one's attention among the great
diversity of other worlds out there or
else on the contrary extremely dangerous
objects Stand Out among others
still there is yet a third category
its anomalous celestial objects
manifesting unusual behavior which is
barely scientifically accountable
objects like that challenge our
knowledge and deserve special attention
this is exactly the kind of world we'll
be looking at now
the year 2009
the environs of the kepler-413 system
an unknown object passes between our
planet and a distant star briefly
reducing its Luminosity astronomers take
this event to be a standard exoplanet
Transit and announce the discovery of a
new Celestial body
High Precision calculations even make it
possible to determine its parameters
the planet turns out to be a cool giant
with a mass of about 25 times that of
the earth and a radius of about 40
percent that of Jupiter however
180 days later another expected Transit
never occurred the planet so clearly
visible in the old data seemed to have
vanished Without a Trace
a dark spot in the Photosphere of the
star or a giant dust cloud moving in its
vicinity would have accounted for the
mysterious phenomenon but these
hypotheses were dispelled when 800 days
later the mysterious object tree
appeared just as suddenly as it had
vanished
the hypothetical Planet eclipsed the
disk of its parents star five times
before disappearing again
still the key to the riddle had been
found
out that kepler-413b has a highly
unusual orbit
the celestial body is located near a
binary star and is .36 astronomical
units from the system's common Mass
center
trajectory is constantly affected by
gravitational perturbations
and the change in gravitation of two
nearby Stars shifts the orbital plane
considerably causing cyclic oscillations
when the deviation reaches its maximum
the object leaves the line of vision and
then returns to it
calculations show that kepler-413b is
orbit oscillates with a periodicity of
about 11 years deviating 2.5 degrees in
each direction from its average value
the planet's own axis of rotation also
changes its position significantly with
a maximum angle of inclination of up to
30 degrees
combined with a notable eccentricity of
the orbit and its periodic shift the
climatic conditions on the surface
change in a bizarre way
the region that receives the most light
from the parent star is constantly
shifting from the equator to the pearls
and back which leads to dramatic
variations in temperature
it is likely that this process generates
huge planetary scale hurricanes which
can be larger than the Great Red Spot of
Jupiter air currents can carry ice
clouds at several kilometers per second
gradually becoming unstable and
dispersing
meanwhile the collision and deformation
of vortices is capable of causing
tremendous atmospheric emissions that
have the power to overcome the planet's
gravity and reach outer space
according to calculations they will hang
a while up there before gravitational
forces pull them back down
all these incredible phenomena make the
planet a rather harsh place
however
it may seem like a tranquil Serene
Island in comparison to the following
World
190 light years from Earth
the environs of the
hd-10606 system
this yellow dwarf
surprisingly similar in parameters to
the sun is orbited by a planet with a
highly variable climate it whizzes
towards its parents Stars rapidly as a
giant Comet burning itself in a hot rays
of its Corona only to retreat to the
periphery of the system
the object is a gas giant with a mass
four times out of Jupiter and a radius
slightly different from that of Jupiter
at the furthest point in its orbit the
planet is 0.88 astronomical units away
from the parent star and receives about
as much heat from it as the Earth does
from the Sun it has been suggested that
this is when clouds consisting of water
vapor droplets ice crystals or even
micro particles of quartz May condense
in its atmosphere and temperatures on
the surface of the hypothetical
satellites of the gas giant could be
comparable to those on Earth
but as the planet gets closer to the
star conditions on it change very
quickly
within 55 days the distance between them
shrinks by a factor of nearly 30 and the
energy flux from the Star increases by a
factor of 800. observations show that
the lowest point in its orbit the
exoplanet's temperature roughly doubles
within a matter of just six hours
from 500 to 1200 degrees Celsius
such drastic changes result in violent
hurricanes which can reach speeds of up
to 5 kilometers per second
by absorbing an incredible amount of
heat the atmosphere of the gas giant
expands so fast that it produces shock
waves capable of sweeping across the
entire planet multiple times
water vapor is broken down into oxygen
and hydrogen by the temperature and
quartz crystals evaporate Without a
Trace early to recondense into gigantic
sand clouds later
in all likelihood
hd80606b is the only planet in its
system
the gravity of another nearby star has
not only warped its orbit
but is also wreaked havoc on the
protoplanetary disk
so the chances of encountering other
large objects nearby are rather slim
however destabilization of a planetary
system due to the interaction of
celestial bodies is not uncommon
[Music]
1530 light years from Earth
the environs of the kepler-36 system
the central object in this system is a
yellow subgiant
its mass is comparable to that of the
Sun and its radius is 62 percent larger
than that of our star there are two
planets rapidly orbiting the star a
rocky super Earth and a hot mini Neptune
every 97 days they mutually Approach at
a critical distance of only 1.9 million
kilometers about 20 times less than the
minimum distance between the Earth and
Venus
such moments their mutual attraction
causes global cataclysms but after a few
days the celestial bodies diverge again
until the next resonance
according to calculations the
gravitational interaction between the
planets the point of closest approach is
about 13 times higher than that between
the Earth and the Moon
in particular this effect should be seen
on the surface of the rocky planet
under the influence of Titanic forces
its crust May Crack and shift causing
earthquakes of incredible power
the resulting chasms may be hundreds of
kilometers long and cause multiple
eruptions of gigantic volcanoes
it is likely that some regions of the
planet do not cool down in the short
period of relative tranquility
creating Seas of eternally bubbling red
hot magma
the reasons for the formation of such an
unusual system are still debatable
we now know that the super Earth dubbed
kepler-36b is 0.12 astronomical units
away from its parent star and it takes
14 days to complete a full orbit around
it
the superette's mass is 3.8 times that
of the earth and its radius is one and a
half times that of our planet
the object has been calculated to have a
temperature of 980 Kelvin or just over
700 degrees Celsius and an average
density of about 30 percent higher than
that of the Earth
the data suggests that the celestial
body could be a thonian planet the core
of a gas giant that has lost its
atmosphere
such objects contain many heavy metals
like iron and Lead as well as sulfur and
silicon compounds
it is likely that the light elements
that once made up the thick dense shell
of the celestial body may have been
blown into space by Stellar Wind nor
should we forget the second planet's
gravitational pull which could
potentially have contributed to this
process
the object is called
kepler-36c and is likely to fall into
the glass of hot mini Neptunes the
celestial body moves in a nearly
circular orbit with a radius of 0.13
astronomical units and completes it
every 16 days
mass is seven times that of our planet
and its radius is 3.7 times that of the
Earth
because of its proximity to the star the
temperature of the object is also very
high
928 Kelvin or 655 degrees Celsius this
Celestial body should be surrounded by a
thick multi-layered atmosphere
consisting mainly of nitrogen hydrogen
and helium
deeper down the pressure inside the gas
shell increases and it gradually turns
into a notion of supercritical fluid
surrounding the solid core
meanwhile under certain conditions truly
fantastic phenomena are also possible
for example the gravity of a more
massive planet can potentially capture
satellites from its smaller companion
while tidal forces May destroy them to
form vast asteroid streams
in addition the mutual gravitational
pull of the two planets distorts their
orbits altering eccentricity and other
parameters
because of this the entire system
behaves chaotically and unpredictably
and its Evolution cannot be predicted
over any extended period modeling shows
a 91 probability that the two planets
will collide with each other over the
next 70 million years producing hundreds
of thousands of pieces of debris which
will disperse throughout the planetary
system thereby creating a still greater
chaos within it such tremendous
cataclysms may have occurred more than
once in the following system
434 light years from Earth
a surprising object informally called
super Saturn is located four
astronomical units away from a young
sun-like star
it is a brown dwarf or a large gas giant
20 times as heavy as Jupiter
observations show it to be a young
Planet about 15 to 16 million years old
which is still forming
most of its atmosphere consists of
hydrogen and helium with a massive
metallic core in its depths
this object is spun by a system of rings
like Saturn's but much larger the
transit method revealed at least 37
distinct trains with the largest ones
outer radius measuring about 0.6
astronomical units this is comparable to
the size of Venus's orbit and about 640
times the radius of Saturn's rings
according to calculations the total mass
of the second planetary disk is bigger
than the mass of the earth and its
Behavior manifests signs of Randomness
mathematical modeling shows that such
structures are not stable and gradually
disintegrate
some of the objects making them up lose
velocity and fall to the central Planet
While others on the contrary accelerate
and leave the disc forever
however this process is greatly extended
in time and may take several hundred
million years
also a large rupture with a radius of
about 0.4 astronomical units was
detected in the system of rings which is
considered in direct evidence of the
existence of a nexo satellite in this
region about 80 percent the mass of the
Earth
according to current understanding of
the physics of space objects it is a
kind of object capable of clearing its
orbit of small debris forming a wide
rupture in the ring structure in
addition observations suggest the
presence of at least two more celestial
bodies
with a mass of each of about 30 percent
that of the Earth are located at a
distance of about 0.25 astronomical
units from the center of the brown dwarf
just like it is the case with a large
planets known to us it can be assumed
that a total of several hundred EXO
satellites including rather massive ones
may be located within the gravitational
influence of the central object
simulation of such a system including
radiation for a parent star heat flow
from a giant planet and tidal influences
shows that the temperature of the
celestial body is making it up could
approach comfortable values
one can only imagine how enchanting the
night sky would be from the surface of
such an exos satellite
at this distance the brown dwarf
occupies 70 times as much space in the
sky as the full moon and its soft glow
can dispel the darkness and turn the
Knight into a misty Twilight
instead of The Star-Spangled canopy the
planet's sky is crisscrossed by vast
swathes of light from Horizon to Horizon
at the same time the tidal forces of a
nearby massive body could provoke
multiple eruptions on a satellite
surface and its hypothetical ocean could
slam the land with giant waves the width
of a tidal Zone under such conditions
could reach hundreds of kilometers
making it a unique climatic Zone
something like a cross between land and
the ocean floor
still it should be mentioned that such
structures tend to be unstable and
change their appearance quite quickly
beyond recognition it is difficult to
say how much longer will be able to
admire the giant rings and what they
will look like in millions of years
deep space is full of mysteries and
surprising objects
they appear to us in the form of many
photographs and vast amounts of
information
gradually revealing their secrets to the
pervasive human curiosity
meanwhile
each Discovery raises new questions
which means that the learning process is
quite endless
and each of your likes helps us create
new and exciting videos about space and
worlds far away and let's keep in touch
[Music]
thank you
foreign